un autre exemple d'atelier pour les
enfants qui se déroul à Manil et cette
semaine oui il s'agit d'un atelier
artistique pour not création de costumes
de princesse alors Julie Rocha Suarez n
va nous en dire quelques
mots une vingtaine de fillettes jouent
les styliste le temps d'une semaine à
l'estaminé café de Manille Lamo pour
l'atelier costume de princesse Léa et
ses copines ont d'abord dessiné puis
colorier la robe de leur rêve avant de
la créer sur les conseils d'une bonne
fée ancienne habilleuse du mou rouge on
avait pas les moyens de se payer des
beaux tissus mais moi j'adore bien
travailler le papier crépon parce que
pourquoi le papier crépon c'est un petit
peu bête mais si je prends les les
stylos de feutre et si je prends le
papier crépon je trouve les mêmes
couleurs pendant ce temps les garçons
fabriquent de leur côté des maquettes de
Châteaufort en carton ondulé les
réalisations seront exposées ce vendredi
autour d'un
goûter et Juliette gosou qu'on aperçu
dans cette interview sera demain sur ce
plateau puisque le 78 sera 100 % féminin
demain à la veille de la Journée
internationale des droits de la femme
présentation féminine que des invité
féminine sur ce plateau voilà pour
occuper la soirée demain 18h 19h pour
évoquer ce cette suite autre atelier
alors cette fois-ci à Versailles c'est
l'osmotèque qui propose donc un atelier
les petitsnés donc il s'agit pour les
enfants de s'initier au monde
descenteurs images de Guillaum Kamp
patchouli Canel rose coriandre autant
d'odeur que nos petitsnz en herbes vont
s'amuser à reconnaître l'Osmothèque de
Versailles lieu unique au monde de
conservation du parfum propose pendant
les vacances un atelier pour enfants de
découverte des senteurs l'idée pour les
enfants c'est d'apprendre deux trois
deux trois idées sur la parfumerie de de
comprendre un petit peu d'où d'où
viennent les matières premières de la
parfumerie qu'elles peuvent en fait
eux-mêmes sentir dans la nature
découvrir que la flur d'orangeer sang
que la rose sang que la lavande et
cetera et puis aussi pour eux faire un
exercice vraiment ludique où ils
essaient de trouver de retrouver l'odeur
qui va avec la petite image qui leur est
présentée un programme ludique et
participatif où chaque enfant peut
s'initier au monde des senteurs en
découvrant leur histoire et en faisant
travailler son nez et sa mémoire
olfactive ce que j'aime bien c'est
sentir les odeurs et en découvrir j'ai
découvert celle du
muguet celle de l'estragon et celle de
la fleur d'oranger pour maintenir en
éveil l'odorat des enfants rien de tel
que de susciter leur intérêt et leur
curiosité un exercice que certains
pratiquent déjà au quotidien grâce à
notre odorat et ben on peut reconnaître
les différents pas les différents goûts
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que tu
faisais déjà à la maison ou quand tu te
promènes dehors bah je faisais souvent
l'atelier d'une durée d'uneh30 est
accessible aux enfants âgés de 8 à 11
ans en dehors des vacances scolaires
petitnz peuvent aussi se retrouver les
mercredis orelia vous étiez sur cet
atelier et oui et bien figurez-vous ça
sent bon mais c'est que c'est pas
évident de de de reconnaître toutes les
senteurs c'est un vrai travail de de
mémorisation et n nos enfants on un
certain talent faut dire c'est un métier
aussi hein il faut dire c'est un métier
on passe à l'agenda culture de cette
édition alors dans cet agenda on va déjà
rappeler que l'office du tourisme de
SaintQuentin niveline propose de
télécharger en libre accès le Petit Futé
donc l'édition 2013 donc entre le 3 et
le 24 mars donc vous allez possibilité
télécharger ce livret sur le site donc
de l'office du tourisme
wwwofficedutourisme.aglo-sqy.fr et puis
concernant nos sorties culturelles alors
on reste dans la thématique des enfants
donc le carnaval des animaux de la ferme
se trouvera donc à la Bergerie Nationale
du 2 au 17 mars donc car Rambouillet il
s'agira d'atelier autour de la
conception de masques fabrication
d'instruments de musique atelier cuisine
et spectacle un riche programme et
également au centre Alfred de viin donc
à voisin le Bretonneux du 4 au 15 mars
ce sont des ateliers slam stage de
peinture chinoise cuisine et danse
africaine voilà pour ce point complet
sur la culture tous ces ateliers qui
vous sont proposés merci Aurélia pour
avoir dressé un petit peu ce tour
d'horizon des différentes animations à
retrouver dans le département cette
édition du 78 qui est quasiment terminée
le rappel des titre à présent quelques
sujets que nous avons développé ce soir
la ligne de train la verrière la défense
réouverte progressivement la circulation
des ce jeudi une reprise partielle avant
une fin des travaux prévu toujours le 14
mars après l'incendie qui avait bloqué
complètement la circulation le quartier
du valibou à plaisir en cours de
rénovation pour éviter les tags sur les
bâtiments et puis offrir au quartier une
vision plus artistique une idée
originale le principe des fresques
participative la population va être mise
à contribution réalisé en partenariat
avec cité création un spécialiste de
l'arme mural qui intervient dans le
monde entier et puis ce weekend
réouverture de France miniatur est en
cours chaque année le site accueille
200000 visiteurs parmi les nouvelles
maquettes que vous avez découvertes ce
soir en cours de réalisation la cité de
Carcasson et puis un atelier autour des
parfum proposé aux enfants de 8 à 11 ans
cela se passe à l'Osmothèque de
Versailles un atelier intitulé Les
petitsnés qui se déroule pendant et hors
des vacances scolaires nous en avons
parlé ce soir au cours de notre page
culture qui est à retrouver dès à
présent sur notre site site internet et
puis je vous donne cette toute dernière
information qui concerne à l'entreprise
Renault le plan de compétitivité a été
accepté aujourd'hui par les principaux
syndicats CFE CGT et FO un plan qui
prévoit un niveau de production minimum
de 710000 véhicules par an jusqu'en 2016
dont 110000 à l'usine de Flin en échange
les salariés devront travailler plus
tout en acceptant un gel de leur salaire
en 2013 signature de cet accord de
compétitivité le 12 mars lors du comité
central de la société en revanche la CGT
reste toujours au posé voilà pour ce
point complet sur l'actualité locale
nouvelle édition du 78 dès demain 18h
vous retrouverez à la présentation
Catherine zulato et également claire
Cambier pour la page économique ce sera
une édition 100 % féminine à la veille
de la Journée internationale des droits
de la femme je vous souhaite une
excellente
soirée